Okay. So this one is the probability diversion because
this is probably because it's one event over.
the sum of two other events
Which are joint probabilities, of
course, it's a joint probability. That's a joint probability a
joint probability. What is this one?
is just going to be
the product of
a joint probability and a marginal probability
So when we plug in the these numbers
we're going to have a numerator and a denominator.
So this will be one ratio comparing
to
events. This will also be a ratio
comparing two events.
So if I were to rewrite these expression if I
were to re-read these terms a little bit we get we get this.
All right. So this is it.
What is the probability that they are guilty?
given a positive test
so they tested positive.
What is the probability that the actually are doping?
so if we plug in
The guilty hypothesis. That's what this
H stands for. So hypothesis guilty.
So that's the a
and of course B is the fact
and of course B is
the positive test
To evaluate this. The first thing we will do is find out
the odds of them being guilty and
we do this this way.
We know that 19 out of those 1,000.
Athletes are guilty.
Right, so we know that 19.
Out of those 1,000 athletes are guilty.
And 931 are
innocent.
If we evaluate this expression.
We will get this other term 1 over
49.
So whatever 49 is the value of this odds.
Again, you can see it's a ratio.
Okay.
And how do we calculate the likelihood?
Now we know that the test has a 95% accuracy.
so the probability
that they would test positive.
Now let me actually put the subscripts here the positive
test because these are positive tests.
Okay, so to evaluate the
likelihood.
for
the equation up here
That's the that's why we want to find out right we know
that the test.
Has a 95% accuracy.
for athletes who are actually doping
so naturally the probability that the
athlete will test positive given they are guilty is 95%
and 5% will hear innocent.
So we have two events.
Once again, we put these two events
inside into a ratio.
That's likelihood.
And we get 19.
That is our likelihood.
Notice that this says that the odds
are 19 times in favor of the numerator.
Your 19 times more likely.
to be
found guilty
by this test
but let's carry on now that we have our odds.
and our likelihood we're going to do some
basic algebra to
get to our posterior likelihood.
And then once we have our posterior likelihood, we will
turn that likelihood into a probability and get
the final result.